on se croirait le dimanche de pâques
bouquet à la main tenue classe et
couronnes de fleurs la rentrée scolaire
c'est une affaire grandiose en russie
c'est non seulement le jour du savoir
c'est une journée de fierté nationale
est bleu ouais bof c'est comme ça
partout pays explique alex et hazard
goff qui organise le grand défilé de la
rentrée dans cette école de lublin eaux
dans le sud est de moscou outre la danse
les champs et cette cloche qui sonne
officiellement la fin des vacances
tous les enfants sont conviés à une
parade militaire à même la toute petite
cour d'école
ces jeunes cadets sont en fait des
élèves part entière ils sont de plus en
plus présent dans le paysage scolaire
on est fiers de les avoir si quelque
chose nous arrive
ils vont nous défendre jusqu'à la fin de
leurs jours 17 petites ces écoles mixtes
où les élèves ordinaires côtoient
désormais les classes de cadettes dès
l'âge de 10 ans viennent s'inscrivent
dans une vaste initiative lancée en 2014
par le président poutine pour mousser
l'éducation patriotique
bright future au conflit lissa et
tatiana sont toutes les deux fier de
porter les épaulettes joindre les cadets
c'était leur choix personnel chez
cordistes leurs chiffres année c'est
bien pour le pays mais surtout ça forge
le caractère
si le but avoué d'intégrer l'option
militaire aux écoles de quartiers et de
gonfler les rangs de l'armée d'ici 2020
tatiana dit qu'elle ne sait pas encore
c'est l'enfant une carrière c'est avant
tout une question de discipline dit
cette mère dont la fille est qu'avec ça
lui rappelle son enfance soviétique mais
que différents elle y voit un
patriotisme qui est sain pour les
enfants selon elle quand les parents
mettent l'uniforme militaire
or leurs enfants c'est bien inquiétant
parce que maintenant c'est pas un jeu il
ya une guerre qui est menée contre
l'ukraine
pour le journaliste yves benny goodman
il n'y a pas que c'est la militarisation
des élèves mais le curriculum scolaire
en soi qui est inquiétant monfils au
disons maintenant il est à l'école
primaire son école est assez libérale
mais parfois il y a des éléments de
l'éducation patriotique
ce sont des éléments assez inquiétant il
donne l'exemple d'un simple examen
durant lequel les enfants ont été
incapables de trouver le nom complet du
président poutine et de son allié
inconditionnel
le maire de moscou les profs ont parlé
aux parents ils ont dit que c'est une
honte tu dois absolument que les parents
doivent enseigner à leurs enfants
le patriotisme toujours tout pour
marquer d'ailleurs s'affronter deux
pouvant poutine qui n'a pas l'habitude
de parader avec les enfants leur a
pourtant consacré toute une partie de
son week-end un jeune lui a demandé
qu'est ce qui les inspire exactement
pour demeurer forts ou spears trop mais
c'est le succès de la russie a répondu
le président souchon ambitieux que
rooney
tous deux succès me donne des ailes